Hello everyone, my friends, my sister.
I feel so fancy with this music.
So refined.
Yes, hello everybody.
Welcome, welcome, welcome.
Welcome back.
If this is your first time watching the Pixel Museum, welcome.
If this is your first time watching me, welcome.
I don't know how to introduce myself.
Why did I make this...
Why did I make this an arbitrary, like, intro?
Why did I... I don't know.
Why did I make this...
I'm so sorry.
Yes, I'm so sorry.
You are a VTuber?
Who am I?
Who's this?
Um...
H...
T...
H...張...
VITAL!
This is my first time watching you, trust.
Who are you?
Why do I feel so... I don't know, on the spot.
But I have to introduce myself.
Such a lust for maids.
First time viewer here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm ignoring the...
The one-year badge.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Show your true nature to all the wisps.
What's my true nature?
Last time watcher.
No, you have to come back!
I'll be so lonely.
This isn't my first time watching you.
Who am I?
Yeah, why are you asking who I am?
Why don't you introduce yourself instead?
Huh?
You come into my chat and you don't introduce yourself?
Hmm...
Show them the power of...
WIT!
Who are we?
WIT.
I'm MintoLover123.
That's not what your username says.
More like...
Phony123.
YouTube got rid of usernames.
Not our fault.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
That's um...
Everybody's username originally was...
MintoLover123 and every number upwards.
So, 1, 2, 3...
1, 2...
Wait...
1, 2, 4...
1, 2, 5...
1, 2, 6...
1, 2, 7...
And onwards and onwards and onwards.
Yeah, yeah, I know, I know.
Oh my goodness.
You guys wrote the super chat.
Today will be Minto.
You are Minto.
Who are we thinking about?
I don't know anymore.
Vintuber, who are you?
Vintuber.
Hello, just a fan of acute ghost mitts.
Understandable.
Good taste.
I never watched you before, or I never will.
My name is Gato, not Gator.
I like robots.
Do you like robots?
Maybe...
I'm just a teacup.
You are!
Thank you so much for the five gifted.
Thank you guys.
Not me, I'm Bintolover123.
Totally different.
My original character.
Do not steal.
Bintol.
I'm missing out.
My name stayed the same.
Yeah, I did.
I prefer that.
First time watching.
I'm sorry.
Sergeant Bobby, thank you so much for the 15 months.
Thank you.
El...
A-ha-roll.
What's up with the gifted?
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
So you admitted that you're cute.
What is this mean girl's moment?
I'm Pippin and I like potatoes.
Oh my gosh.
I don't know.
Oh, I...
I...
Oh, what was it?
Oh!
Um...
I saw...
Someone recreate that...
Heee...
The other day!
And it had me thinking about old memes.
And then like how sometimes people will still reference...
Potatoes, boil em...
Mash em...
Stick em in a stew.
I saw, like, I saw that reference recently, too.
I was like, no, what?
Oh, they're sending the... They're sending the... They're sending the... Oh, what were they?
They're going to Isagard.
What are those things?
Ouch.
Don't tell me.
They're sending... My brain wants to say elves, but it's...
It's the elf guy that says it.
They're sending the elves to Isagard.
No, they're not.
Why don't they send everybody to Isagard?
VK!
Hobbits!
They're sending the hobbits to Isagard.
Isagard!
What is, Isagard a nice place?
Surprise, Lord of the Re... Lord of the Reference.
No, it's not good.
Isagard is awful.
It is the... Lord of the Flies.
Back off.
Lord of the Reference now.
Wait, was it called?
Lord of the Flies?
Yeah.
No, gosh.
Guys, I...
Tomorrow... Okay, let's start playing the game.
Before I forget...
This way?
This one took me forever.
Um, my brain is so... Not great today.
What about Epic Sax Guy with Gandalf nodding?
Wait, I don't think I know that one.
Feeling the need for... Lord of the Rings trilogy watch-along.
I clearly need it because I can't remember Hobbits or...
Or Isagard or anybody.
I can't remember any of this stuff.
We start in small.
I don't know how I want to start today.
I guess we could start small.
15 by 15.
For those who don't know...
These are...
Pixel.puzzle.
I'll explain.
You have all these numbers up top.
All these numbers on the side.
So this is 1, 3, 1.
Which means...
That the dots will appear in this row.
As one.
With a space.
At least one space.
Three.
One.
And then eventually...
It creates a picture.
Nonograms!
Yeah!
It's time to have a Lord of the Rings watch-along with Wawa.
She would greatly...
She would be greatly disappointed if she saw a clip of the Hobbits.
Don't show her then.
Don't show her then, please.
Oh, I have to challenge it.
Okay.
Here we go.
Start up!
Oh, I forgot that this one shows like...
It turns blue when it shows...
Something you can do.
So see...
Out of this 15, we know that...
The 9 will always overlap here.
Which is why I can put it in.
And then this...
The 3...
Is to be the first number.
So we know...
It can't be...
It has to be like...
1, 2, 3...
Or 1, 2, 3...
Like that.
Your aura today is nice and round.
Are you saying I put on weight?
Some kind of pixel Sudoku.
Pretty much.
Yes!
No, it's Spectra.
If you say so.
And then like 8 can be here.
But then also...
We can...
So since there's 3...
We can go 1, 2, 3...
And then also add the space in.
Like that.
What was the X?
There we go.
We can do that...
Because 6 has to...
6 wouldn't be able to fill in here.
Like that.
Oh wait, I can do one more.なるほど .なるほど.
This is 5... Wait.
1, 2... Oh wait, okay.
Hold on.
1, 2, 3, 4.
Oh, we can fill this in.
Oops.
Yippee!
Easy peasy .なるほど.
And then since these are...
1s...
We know that there's gonna be spaces in between.
Like so.
It was my birthday the other day.
I think I can get a Slightly Belated B-Day song.
TXR!
I'm so sorry.
I'm not doing birthday songs right now.
But...
Happy Belated Birthday!
Happy, happy, belated birthday!
Why couldn't 6 fit in there?
Because there was this little X.
Oh wait.
Hold on.
Let me make myself a little bit smaller.
There we go.
And so there's only 4 spots.
6 wouldn't be able to fit in there.
There we go.
And we can do that.
So we can do that.
Because 4.
But yeah, guys.
I don't know.
I...
I didn't sleep well last night.
I have my throat doctor appointment tomorrow.
I've never...
I don't know.
I've never gotten it done before.
The tube in my throat.
I'm scared.
That's right.
For real.
Uh-oh.
Wait.
Did I mess up already?
I messed up already.
Uh-oh.
Maybe I chose the wrong game to play today.
Wait.
Okay.
Hold on.
Let me reset.
Restart!
I'm so scared tomorrow though.
I'm so scared.
Okay.
Hold on.
What's it?
One.
Two.
Three.
Four.
Wait.
One.
Two.
Three.
Four.
Space.
One.
Two.
Three.
Four.
There we go.
Okay.
Like that.
Should be it.
It's gonna be okay.
Plus you get cool pics.
our video.
Uh-oh.
Ah-oh.
Guru guru.
Guru guru guru.
Wait.
Oh, I forgot that, uh...
The scroll.
The scroll does that.
Whoopsie.
Teeheehee.
I'm scared.
Guru guru.
But yeah.
Uh-oh.
Okay.
But I'll be brave...
Maybe...
The retired play is something relaxing and not stressful.
This isn't stressful...
But my brain is very slow today.
I...
To be honest, I was like...
I was like...
Trying to figure out what to play today.
Because I was like...
I even took a nap...
For like over an hour.
I'm still so sleepy.
Did they give you any instructions?
I don't think so.
I probably just won't eat in the morning.
I'm afraid of throwing up.
I'm so scared.
I'm so scared!
Okay, hold on.
Let me lock in.
It says I can do something here, but...
Here's the...
Hold on.
1...
2...
3...
1...
2...
3...
4...
I'm gonna assume.
1...
2...
3...
4...
5...
That's right.
We can assume.
This is stressful.
The column that says 3, then 8 below it, but...
2 were pressed, and then 5 below that.
Wait, what?
Huh?
You're confusing me even more!
It's okay, we'll get it eventually.
Doesn't matter.
Okay, 4...
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7...
Like that.
For those who don't get it...
It'll...
You'll get it eventually, probably.
Like that.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
A lot of it is kind of pattern recognition, you know?
Because...
You'll eventually be like, oh, if it looks like this, it has to be like this.
You know?
Thanks for getting me addicted to Meow Tower.
I'm almost 100% through the hard puzzles.
Oh my gosh!
I feel like...
I feel like I've gotten so many people addicted to Meow Tower.
It's my greatest...
It's my greatest accomplishment, maybe.
In Afterlife.
Like that.
They should sponsor you.
I know, right?
They should.
5...
7...
8...
Like that.
Oh, wait.
Okay...
And then 2.
Hold on.
I'm gonna turn down...
I'm gonna turn down the clicky-clacky noise.
It's kind of driving me insane.
Sound effects, maybe?
Wait, this is so chill!
You solve these so quickly, it's kind of scary.
Really?
I feel like I'm actually quite slow.
Konnichiwa!
Naano, are you out here helping explain things?
I like this BGM.
I wanna keep it.
Wait, hold on.
Maybe...
Puzzle BGM 3.
Let's just change everything to Puzzle BGM 3.
This is so nice!
And we have completed this row.
Yatta!
Yes, yes.
Oh, so we've completed...
That row.
And this...
Close...
This...
Thank you!
I see a shape.
I see a shape forming...
Oop, that's not what I meant to do.
There we go.
Zeke?
Thank you so much for the gift of Deku!
Speaking of Metal Gear...
Oh my gosh, did you guys see...
The new dinosaur's name in the new Jurassic Park?
Little dragon, thank you so much for the supertante!
Thank you!
I was like, do they know?
Do they know?
It's called...
D-rex!
I was like, there's so many layers here!
D-rex...
Do they know?
Oh...
I got it!
Amazing!
Okay...
Wait, there we go.
Diamond Rex...
It stands for dinosaur.
No, no...
It stands for diamond...
Like diamond dogs...
Like D-dog and D-horse...
D-rex...
Welcome to the diamond dogs!
This works!
D-rex...
Actually, yeah...
I was like...
D-rex?
What...
This is...
This name!
This name...
D-rex...
Okay then that's for certain.
Then I guess it's... wait no.
That's for certain.
Doubtful Rex.
I was thinking the other day, I was just like, oh my gosh.
Maybe I'll play... the new Metal Gear on my...
Um... On my... PS5.
Because probably... like... I'm... 90% sure I'm gonna lag like crazy.
But then I remembered that I... did this special pre-order.
The one that uh... The one that allows you to play early a couple days.
I did that on Steam.
Aw man... I messed up.
I... I did a silly.
I like the far left column.
This one?
Why?
Why do you like it?
Okay, hold on.
It says I know it, but I don't know it.
Hmm... curious.
I'm curious.
Um... Hmm... Hmm... Like that.
Naruhodo!
Yes.
How?
Oh, I was looking at the wrong one.
Oh my goodness!
Oh my goodness.
You get it now?
We just have to use Chimiminto.
Yeah, I guess so.
Wait.
Three... This is seven.
There we go.
Naruhodo!
Hmm... Hmm...
What could this be?
It kind of looks like... a worm.
Maybe.
I mean...
Kind of... Hold on.
I'm gonna... Let's see.
Ha ha ha!
I'm a genius?
Hmm... Hmm...
I am a genius.
Yes.
Naruhodo!
Yaatta!
Hehehe!
Mehehehe.
Ehm...
Ehm... Ehm... I can't stop seeing the...
Eyeball of the worm.
Ha ha ha ha ha.
Um.
I can't un-see it.
Yuh...
Mm hmm!
Sugoi!
I feel like I'm gonna fall asleep at any moment.
Uh-oh.
I feel like this is making me so sleepy.
Almost there!
Yippee!
It's a worm!
It's the Alba Madonna!
Let's listen to the...
A worm!
Oh, I'm taking notes!
Okay, that was a nice warm-up, huh?
Actually...
What size is this?
Oh, this is another 15x15.
Easy peasy!
You have a good memory?
I almost wish I had like a...
Photographic memory or something.
But...
Maybe you don't learn so much with just a photographic memory, you know?
Oh...
You don't retain it for long term...
Oh, this one's super easy.
Yatta!
This one's so easy!
I'm all over the place, though.
My brain is a lint roller.
In...
In what way?
Before my membership expires, I want to say...
Thank you, Dr. Professor, for your...
Wise words.
Thank you!
This one is complete!
That's right!
That's great!
Thank you!
Four, five, six, seven...
That's right!
Oh, we can complete...
That...
That's nice!
This one's very easy.
Do you guys see the vision yet?
You see the vision...
Yatta!
It's an apple.
Hmm?
That's right!
Is it an apple?
Place your bets?
I'm just double counting everything...
Yatta!
Okay.
Oh, boy!
In the sentence...
Ngunly...
THE WHO LOOK ABOUT IT.
Yeah, by that.
The Britishman!
Ngunly...
Yes, Yatta!
That's right!
The Britishman...
Is it an apple?
Yes, man.
Yes, man!
Nintendo!
You see...
The Britishman.
Easy.
It's a person.
It's a guy.
It's that.
It's Rembrandt.
Rembrandt.
Ed Sheeran.
The Maestro.
Pro Tag Hair Stag.
Oh!
He was just talking about his hair.
Interesting.
I did notice how the strokes of the hair looked so interesting.
He's kind of a child.
Especially here.
Oh!
I forgot what this means.
Oh, but I didn't finish.
Oh, that's what we did.
40 by 30.
That was my largest ever, ever, ever...
Painting that I've ever dot... or, uh, P-Cross...
Nonogram I've ever dot in.
Never done one bigger than 40 by 30.
It was really long.
Wait, I wonder if it says...
How long it took me...
Almost two hours!
Almost two whole hours of just that one.
Maybe we should do...
The room in the back?
She's trying to get me into the back rooms?
Wait, this one?
What?
This is the special one, eh?
You get the sense there's a story behind this one.
It's 25 by 30.
Let's try it.
This one will take me much longer because I...
You know...
Before I can be kind of used to the pa...
Okay, hold on.
We just started the stream.
Let me...
Have a little bit more...
15 by 15.
Give me...
Wait, special artworks room.
Maybe it's here.
Oh...
Nevermind, that is the one.
Oh wait...
Can I not?
F1...
Nevermind.
How do I get to another level?
Oh wait, I think here.
Here we go, here we go, here we go, here we go, here we go.
Let's do 15 by 15.
Okay, easy.
I really like nonograms, you guys.
Ah!
There we go.
Oopsie.
I caught it.
I caught it, I caught it.
That was just me...
Going too fast.
The...
Meow Tower that I usually play...
Catches your mistakes...
Like immediately.
So if I mess up...
It...
Immediately will clock me.
So I'm so used to...
Immediately being...
Immediately...
Immediate...
Uh...
What's the word?
I'm used to the immediate...
Um...
Feedback.
I prefer when it doesn't do that.
Me too, honestly.
I wish you could turn it off.
Especially because it also kind of has like a grading system.
Um...
So...
If you mess up so many times...
And sometimes it's not even me messing up.
Sometimes it's me like...
Miss clicking, you know?
Like uh...
Like I know it's the wrong thing.
I just...
My hand slipped or something.
You know?
Yeah...
But...
It...
There's one?
Oh my gosh.
It was the...
Hatsune Miku one.
It's so unforgiving.
Because...
Um...
Two...
One...
Uh...
Because...
It also costs...
Like you have stamina to play and everything.
I hate that too.
No...
Have no idea how to play PCOS, but this stream has two cute girls.
So...
Respect.
Maitake, Maitake, Gulu, Gulu, Gulu, Gulu!
Thank you!
Miku PCOS 2 next week.
Maitake, Maitake, Gulu, Gulu, Gulu, Gulu!
There we go.
Really?
They're making another one?
Let's go.
This one's pretty easy too.
I say that if...
I don't know if I'm messing up.
Huh...
Who knows?
See ya!
Three or two!
Who knows?
Not me.
Huh...
I don't mean to do that one.
There we go.
Okay...
Three...
Two...
I'm literally on autopilot right now.
I can't tell if this is right at all.
Oh, okay.
Logite art grimoire by the same dev has grid nonograms and some cool...
Metal games.
King Charles Spaniel.
There's a dog!
See that Picross crime slash Ace Attorney like any...
I have seen that!
I wanna...
Oh my gosh, look at how stinking cute King Charles Spaniel is.
You knew it was a dog?
I can never... I'm so focused on the puzzle!
I can't never tell.
I can't even tell what it is until I'm done.
Oh my gosh, an artist that knows how to paint a dog!
Wow!
Wow.
An artist that knows that dogs look like dogs and not human.
I can see it.
Hold on.
There we go.
Sorry, I'm fixing something.
Well, we did three 15x15s.
Have you seen Superman?
No.
I don't usually go to the movies.
I also don't watch...
Uh...
Superhero movies.
Shall we do the special one?
Corona is that breed of dog.
A spaniel?
I have no idea.
So tired of comic book films.
I think...
a lot of people are.
I think a lot of people are.
I usually...
If there's a movie I want to watch, I wait until it's on the plane.
And then I'm still waiting for the Minecraft movie to be on the plane.
So I can watch it.
It's like I spend so much money for a plane ticket.
And it's...
It's really instead a movie theater visit.
But there are so few superhero movies.
I bet you would catch up in no time.
The last superhero movie I watched...
Besides falling asleep to Deadpool Wolverine.
I tried watching that.
I fell asleep.
Literally at the beginning of the movie.
Um...
But the last movie I watched was...
Then probably...
When the first Iron Man came out.
Yeah.
Yeah, I think that's the last one I watched.
A long time ago.
I told you, I don't go watch superhero movies.
Well...
Wait.
When did Captain America come out?
Because I watched that first one too.
America.
No, movie...
Movie one.
2011.
And then...
Iron Man.
Movie one.
2008.
Okay, so then maybe Captain America was the last one I watched.
Wait.
I think?
I think I watched it.
I feel like I watched it.
I don't remember anything that happens in it though.
He gets frozen, right?
Yeah?
Yeah, at the end.
Okay.
Oh, that's a spoiler.
Wait, how is that spoilers?
Is that...
That are not...
Exactly what you know about...
Captain America?
Okay.
We're gonna do a 25 by 30, guys.
This might be the rest of the stream.
Okay.
Holy moly.
Five...
I'm already...
I'm already getting...
Jumbled.
Five...
One...
Two...
Three...
Four...
Five...
One...
Two...
Three...
Wait, can I put a...
Okay, I can put this.
One...
Two...
Three...
Four...
Five...
Six...
Seven...
Eight...
Nine...
Ten...
Okay.
One...
Two...
Three...
Four...
Five...
Six...
Seven...
Eight...
Nine...
Ten...
20...
What was it?
25 by 30 or something?
Five...
Ten...
Fifteen...
Twenty...
Five...
Ten...
Fifteen...
Twenty...
Okay, yes.
Okay, so this is...
One...
Two...
Three...
Four...
Five...
One...
Two...
Three...
Four...
There we go.
Ahh...
Seventeen...
Maybe somewhere in the middle, no?
They had to Photoshop Chris Evans to be skinny in Captain America, what?
What do you mean?
What?
It's melting my brain.
Me too.
It's a little gun shooting.
Fifteen...
Sixteen...
Seventeen...
Five...
Ten...
Fi...
Fifteen...
Sixteen...
Seventeen...
Um...
Like that.
So then, would this be like this?
It seems to be the case.
Five...
Ten...
Fifteen...
Sixteen...
Yeah, yeah, okay.
And so...
Five...
Like that.
Hum-hum...
Two...
Three...
Four...
Five...
Three...
Now we're cooking.
You sound tired?
I am tired, but I'm also concentrated.
Uh, I really didn't know what to do today.
Okay.
So I'm sorry that it's, you know, just me being like... Puzzle Cam.
Mince more into Rich Evans than Chris Evans.
Chris Evans is Captain America.
Wait.
There's another Evans, no?
Oh, who's the other Evans?
That's not Rich Evans.
Who isn't into Rich Evans?
So true.
Chris Evans' real name.
There's another Chris.
Oh, maybe I'm thinking of Chris then.
Because there's another Chris in the cinematic universes.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12, 13, 14, 15, 16.
Okay, that actually knocked out a ton.
Oh, oh.
I misread.
Okay.
Chris Hemsworth.
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
He is...
Thor.
Loki is Chris, too?
No, Loki is...
Cumberbatch.
1, 2, 3, 4...
Chris...
What's his name?
Not Chris.
No.
Benedict Cumberbatch.
No?
I'm wrong?
Oh, Tom.
Thomas Hiddleston.
Hiddleston.
I said it with such confidence, too.
Cumberbatch is Dr. Strange.
I'll never understand any of this.
7, 8, 9.
I swear...
I'll never understand...
2, 3, 4, 5, 6...
5, 6, 7, 8.
It's not worth understanding.
Chris Pratt is Star-Lord.
That is...
Guardians of the Galaxy.
I know, I know.
He's Mario, unfortunately.
Yeah.
I know that, too.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10.
I was like...
I was about to say, did I mess up?
Oh my gosh, I was so scared for a second.
Okay, nice.
We got a side.
That's always...
That's always a good thing to get.
Yeah.
I believed in you.
Yeah!
Just joined.
Is this Minesweeper?
Mm-hmm.
And if I get it wrong, we all explode.
I put a little bit of ectoplasm inside each and every one of your brains.
And if I get it wrong...
I will activate that ectoplasm.
So that...
Isn't every single person here...
Goes...
Keep nono grabbing, but it explodes.
Luckily...
I'm...
I'm pretty good at this.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10.
Luckily, you have nothing to worry about.
You would trust me.
Or you would trust your life...
In my hand.
Right?
You would.
This is probably like that.
And then...
Like that.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10.
I hope that's right.
Or else we're...
Going out!
We're going to hell, baby!
Oh my gosh.
Have you guys seen that ride at Disneyland?
Okay.
It's called...
I always confuse it with the Mr. Bones Wild Ride.
It's, uh...
Mr. Toad's...
Wacky Bizarre Adventure or something.
Wait.
Mr. Toad Ride.
Mr....
Oh, it is Mr. Toad's Wild Ride.
Wait.
What's Mr. Bones?
Wacky Bizarre Adventure or something.
See you guys at Respawn.
Trust in Minto.
Yeah.
Mr. Toad's Wild Ride.
I've never seen the movie.
Mr. Bones is the rollercoaster tycoon map.
Yeah, yeah.
Is it also called Mr. Bones Wild Ride?
Okay.
So basically, I'm going to describe to you...
Mr. Toad's Wild Ride.
And Mr. Toad's Wild Ride is...
Okay.
So...
I've never seen the movie, like I said.
But you...
I don't know.
You are in a car.
And you're like...
Beep, beep.
Broop, broop.
I'm Mr. Toad.
And I'm driving here.
And you're driving, you're driving, you're driving.
And then...
This is the ride, okay?
You're driving.
And you're getting into all sorts of shenanigans.
You're crashing into people.
You almost get run over by a train.
You are...
You are on the wildest ride of your life.
And then...
You have to pay for your crimes.
And so you go to court...
And you are sentenced...
Guilty!
And you are...
Sentenced to death.
And then at the end of the ride...
You get sent to hell.
And then it ends.
And so...
At the end of the ride...
You are driving around in hell.
And then it ends.
The end.
Sounds like a fever dream.
No, it's a wild ride.
It's so... It's such a funny ride, no?
Oh, wait.
Oh, one, two, I can't count.
I was right the first time.
One, two, three, four, five, six.
But I've never seen the movie, so I really actually... I feel like it's a good advertisement for it, no?
Because it makes you want to be like... What is this about?
This one's so confusing.
I should probably lock in, huh?
Or else I'm gonna get...
Stupid.
One?
Okay, five, ten.
Five, ten, eleven, twelve.
Wait.
It has to be this.
It has to be that, no?
One, two, three, wait.
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight, nine, ten, eleven, twelve, thirteen.
Like that?
Is that right?
I can't count!
I can't count.
Makes you go, what the F is this?
I must know more.
Apparently he never dies in the movie.
Then why are we in hell?
In the ride!
Why are we in hell in the ride?
Press C?
Ah, I forgot about this!
Oh my gosh, thank you so much.
I completely forgot about this feature.
Ah, thank you!
Thank you!
Okay, so here's an example of like a tricky part, right?
So it's one, two, five.
You could assume...
You can't assume in this game because...
Guys, this could be one, and then two here, and then five.
Or, it could be five, where you connect this, and then two, and then one.
It's, it's very...
It's very, very tricky.
Okay.
And we just...
Figured it out.
We just...
We just figured it out.
The trick...
Is in the possibilities.
Two.
Yes.
I feel like one...
Oh, okay.
So this should be 11.
Yeah.
Okay, nice!
Nice, nice, nice.
One.
How far is 10?
If Doom has taught me anything, you just...
You don't need to die to go to hell.
You just need to be angry in that.
I was looking at...
I don't wanna...
The new Nothing Phone.
Have you guys seen it?
The Nothing Phone 3?
I even...
There was even an ad for it.
In Japan.
But, um...
There's...
There's like...
I...
I'm kind of a sucker for like...
Phones with gimmicks, you know?
The what?
It's the Nothing Phone!
It's got like no stupid bloatware on it or anything.
And, uh...
Um...
What's the gimmick?
I'm about to tell you.
So the...
It has a little gimmick on it.
Or on the back of the phone.
Um...
On the top right...
Part of the screen.
Or the...
The...
Not the screen.
The back of the phone.
There's a tiny little like...
Pixel circle.
And you can...
Put apps on it.
Like...
You can put like a spin the bottle app on it.
Or a timer on it.
Or...
Um...
You can even use it as like...
A tiny...
Pixelated...
Uh...
Camera?
If you're like using the back...
Camera to try and take a selfie.
And the reason I brought it up is because...
I saw a comment...
Of someone saying...
How long is it going to take...
Before they put Doom on this tiny...
On the tiny screen!
And you know what?
Valid question.
No time at all.
I know, right?
Flip phones had this feature in 2007.
Yeah, but we've regressed with phones a lot.
You know?
We truly have.
See?
This could be one, one.
And then two.
And then...
Another two.
And then five.
So we cannot trust.
Hmm...
We used to have so many cool features on phones.
And now every phone is the same.
So that's why I think I get so excited over like...
A little gimmick like that.
Spin the bottle app.
Feeling old.
I remember when actual bottles were a thing.
I was gonna say...
You remember when actual spin the bottle was a thing?
Because, uh...
Wow, you did...
You played spin the bottle?
What are you, a Riaju or something?
Hmm...
Riaju.
Playing spin the bottle.
One...
Two...
Three...
Four...
Wait, hold on.
It was here, right?
Oh no, it was here.
One...
Two...
Three...
Four...
Five...
Six...
Seven...
Eight...
Nine...
Ten...
Wait, what were bottles invented?
No one actually played spin the bottle?
It was a meme?
You're gonna tell me next that...
Seven minutes in heaven wasn't real either.
You're gonna tell me that...
Nobody ever did seven minutes in heaven either.
We can make it real?
Ooh, that lot!
Sucker for gimmicks reminds me I have to...
Still get myself a play date.
Gameboy with a crank is the gimmick.
Haha!
Wait, I don't know that.
Sorry Mint, they don't actually go to heaven.
You know, from my experience, that might be for the best.
Huh?
Let's see...
Two...
One...
Wait, two...
Space...
Eight...
Nine...
Okay.
Play date actually has some good games on it too?
Really?
Wait, I've never heard of this thing.
I don't know.
How have I never heard?
Yes...
One...
Two...
Three...
Four...
Five...
Oh my goodness.
And now we have eight here.
Wait...
Like that?
And we can get rid of that.
So far, this one's not as...
As evil as the one before.
Better to be with Minto than be in heaven.
No, don't say that.
Unique indie handheld.
Whoa!
This looks like a hand.
Maybe.
One...
Space.
Nice.
I'm gonna check if there's any mistakes.
Just wait.
I'm a genius.
Nice.
Stars.
Win with Minto.
I'm in heaven.
Stop!
You're just making fun of me.
Wait.
I think I messed this up.
Yeah, there we go.
That should be right.
I hope...
She doesn't believe us.
I...
Don't believe many things.
But I do believe in ghosts.
And I should do.
How am I supposed to know this?
Twenty.
Eleven.
One...
Ghost?
You are watching a ghost right now.
I'm afraid of no ghosts.
One...
Space.
Okay.
Yeah, I did that one.
Space...
Like that, okay.
Hopefully that's right.
I'm scared.
What if it's not?
This one's bizarre so far.
Do you believe that we love and support you?
I
don't know.
Rose means love at first sight.
Okay, but I really... I don't like this...
Taste of rose.
I don't think I'm alone in that either.
I don't like the... You know, like if something's a rose...
Taste.
You know, like a rose tea or rose drink.
Oh wait, that's the same.
Rose...
I don't like it.
I don't believe in ghosts.
There's a mass hallucination caused by gasoline.
Also blue, thank you.
I believe in one ghost.
Thanks for showcasing this game.
I love Picross likes.
Thank you.
Me too.
Space.
Can't be that.
Okay, okay, okay.
You don't like rose, but what about Jack?
Oh my gosh, Titanic watch along.
Okay.
Okay, so because this one is a one...
This one has to be the one...
Other one.
Because...
It's above...
The two.
So there's no way it would be the two, you know?
So we finally figured that out.
We finally figured that out.
Good, good.
Isn't Turkish delight...
Oh my gosh, I had Turkish delight once.
And I...
Hated it.
Maybe...
I didn't wait.
Is it actually rose flavored?
Maybe that's why I hated it.
Two.
Ah, hate.
Hate it.
It's like the most disappointing sweet ever.
It's not a delight at all.
It's such false advertising.
Oh, this scared me.
I was like, oh no, there's not enough room for six.
Okay, so then...
We can do...
That.
And that.
Good, good, good, good, good.
How am I supposed to know this?
Oh, that's why.
Hold on, hold on.
I didn't realize.
I didn't seal it up.
We're like, running out of blue spots, you know?
Yes.
We'll be sure to gift you Turkish delight.
You'll watch me spit it out.
Never care for Turkish disappointment.
At least you know what you're getting.
You know?
Imagine being advertised as a Turkish delight.
And it just makes you feel dread and anger.
Oh.
Oh my gosh, I was looking...
I was...
I thought I was looking at this one and being like...
Oh my gosh, no.
Oh no, stop.
Stop.
I was scared for a second.
So, did a cute girl make you waffles today?
Or did you get something else for breakfast?
In the end...
My breakfast was so disappointing.
In the end, I had to have leftover pizza.
It was the last of my leftover pizza.
Why are you eating roses, Minky?
Taste of rose...
There's a...
Actually, rose flavored stuff is so common though, no?
I feel...
Yeah, I feel like I see rose flavored things all the time.
Horrible.
I don't know.
Seven...
Yeah, okay.
What is this?
It looks like a mangled hand.
I can't tell.
I had leftover pizza.
Besties!
How do you know I didn't possess you and eat your pizza?
You know?
I'm just saying, it's more likely than you think, possession.
Position.
More than once.
That's it!
Hmm, hmm.
What toppings?
Do you really wanna know?
You won't judge me?
People get so defensive over their pizza choices.
Their pizza toppings?
They say, if you don't have the same topping as me...
You are...
Considered...
The devil.
No judgment, Minto?
I'll judge you a little.
Okay!
I had...
It was a...
It was a pineapple and spinach.
Spinach.
I've been trying to eat more spinach lately.
I like making spinach...
And...
Sesame oil.
You know, you can...
Wait.
You can what?
Oh, sorry.
You can just ask me when someone's talking...
Sulkababa's homemade pizza.
That sounds yummy.
Homemade pizza?
Fancy.
Fancy, fancy.
I didn't...
That's right.
We did it!
Oh my gosh!
We actually finished a row!
A row.
Wait.
Just kidding.
Oh shoot.
Uh...
Actual undue moment.
GULULU GULU GULU!
GULU GULU GULU!
Actual rewind moment.
I don't know if this is a 2.
Wait, actually, what is this?
Yeah, see, see, see?
You can never be so sure.
I have no clue what's going on, but this is fire.
I'm glad you like it.
Glad when we can just kind of chill.
Sorry, I'm very low energy today.
I'm... oh.
I'm just so scared.
Oh, I'm scared.
I was like, I won't cry on stream.
I won't do it, but I'm scared.
Ah, wait.
Oh, no!
Mistake!
Wait, wait, grudu grudu.
Uh-oh.
Just wait a minute.
Here.
Okay, I felt like this had to be... wait.
And here.
Oh, yeah.
Wait, this is... wait.
Eh?
Oh?
Wait.
Eh?
Ah.
Why did I put that?
Why did I put that there?
Because... yeah, obviously that doesn't even equal to 8.
Maybe I meant to put...
This... that... and I accidentally put...
The X.
I do that sometimes.
Then this part is also wrong, right?
It said?
Oh.
Oh, I think that's why I got it wrong.
Maybe I just miscounted.
Oh, I think that's why I got it.
That's why I got it.
This is a lot of Q-L... Q-O-L features that I like from a PCross.
Right!
It's actually so...
It's so easy to get into.
It's so nice.
Your appointment is going to be fine.
But head pats and hugs make you feel better.
Thank you.
I'm so scared.
I've never had the tube.
For those who don't know, I have a doctor's appointment for my throat tomorrow.
No, it's not hot dog at all.
Huh.
It's going to be nervous.
Wisps only wish Minto the best at their appointment.
And that you'll come out stronger and healthier than ever.
Gamba, Minto.
Thank you.
Ghost doctor.
Yes, at the Boospital.
Yes, yes.
You would think.
After death, things would be easier, huh?
What's the point of dying if I still get sick?
What's the point?
I see.
This also feels wrong.
I'm going to get sick!
I'm going to
get sick!
I'm going to get sick!
Huh?
Maybe I just counted wrong.
Oh?
Maybe I counted...
No, right?
Life or death, existence is suffering...
Exactly!
But this is impossible.
I can't fit three...
Oh, the two is over here!
I'm a silly Willy.
That's why I was so confused.
The developer Jupiter Core made a lot of PCOS games, especially my Nintendo.
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
I didn't remember that.
That's what you're making.
That should be that.
What?
Wait, where did the 11 go?
Yes.
I think so.
Oh...
That's right.
There we go.
Sure.
See, it's so easy for me to accidentally click the wrong thing.
That's great!
I had camera down my throat last week.
Took only 15 minutes and I slept through it.
I don't think...
I don't think I'm sleeping.
I don't think so.
Support me!
Thank you!
I think I'm gonna be...
Awake though!
Cause wouldn't they tell me?
That...
Um...
I need someone to...
Drive me there.
Sorry.
I'm scared!
The down the mouth is too scary.
I could...
Reach the throat from the butt.
So true.
I think someone else had to do that too.
Kind of like a two-in-one deal.
I'm too scared.
I don't wanna think about it.
They did genius.
You can do it, Bryce.
I have to.
That's the only thing.
It's not that I can do it.
It's not that I have to...
Have to do it.
No matter if I want to or not.
Maybe I should...
I don't know.
I'll expose myself to more pains.
It's what being a ghost is all about.
Being in pain.
I got it.
Still no idea what this picture is.
I believe it has to be a corner of a painting.
Because what the hell?
What the hell?
I don't know either.
I like it.
Yes, yes.
Amazing!
Very...
Wait,
this is correct, right?
Nope.
It's so easy...
To be wrong.
Be so confidently wrong.
If you walk in and see the tube looks suspiciously wisp-shaped, please pay me no mind.
I mean pay it, don't worry.
Yeah, I wish you guys could join me.
Keep me company there.
Wait,
it kind of looks like a person...
With...
Killing another person.
You guys see it?
It kind of looks like this person's dead on the ground and this person's stabbing them.
I think.
There's so few blues here.
Wait, how can I figure...
Oh wait, this is 2...
1-1.
Oh, here we go.
Wait.
I messed up.
Uh-oh.
Wait, wait.
Oh, I... I mixed up the one.
That's right.
There we go.
Okay.
Just click.
Awesome!
Someone who has been awake for a camera in this...
In this...
In the...
Huh?
It makes me flinch.
It makes me...
Spiritually cringe.
Oh.
Oh, I don't like that.
I don't like that one bit.
I'm sure you didn't either.
I'm sure you also didn't like that one bit.
I'm sure you're ready.
And just like that, you're ready.
I'm...
That doesn't make me feel any better.
That doesn't make...
I don't think so.
I feel like I might pass out actually.
Okay...
Two...
One... Oh, wait, no.
There we go, okay.
I'm mixed.
Uh, so this is four.
There we go, okay.
And then two and one, okay.
Two...
One...
Two.
Okay.
I can't... I think it's someone getting stabbed.
I think it's someone getting stabbed.
I believe.
Get stabbed, get stabbed.
I'll say.
Who's that?
Oh.
... Wolfen.
ok.
...etsu ni it we Yeah ...
A serious paper cut.
Vermeer?
Yeah, that's what I was thinking!
Yeah, Vermeer!
Oh my gosh, we do!
We do!
Oh my gosh, this is the first sentence.
So, the use of the技術 is wonderful, but this is the story of the story.
At the time, the letter is a very small number of words.
That's why, the letter is a far away from the相手 and a直接 to meet the相手 and the relationship between the two and the relationship.
What was the letter?
How was the letter?
Do you think it's related to the story behind the world's map?
See, I didn't even notice the map on the wall, but Vermeer has a very specific way of...
of painting clothing and also, like...
the... the... the brightness of the color, so I could tell.
Letter from a lover?
Ooh la la!
You think it's steamy?
Thanks for this chill stream.
Had a long day.
Not bad, just long.
That was good that it wasn't bad.
And this is just the speed for me.
I love this game, too.
Love all the stuff you've been up to lately.
Take care of yourself.
Thank you, Lunar!
Thank you!
You take it easy, too.
I know my art.
I know just a few artists.
Yeah.
Privet from Russia!
Speaking of museums, be sure to visit St. Petersburg... St. Petersburg someday!
It's one of the most beautiful cities.
Full of museums, theaters, and other cultural attractions related to our thousand-year history!
Oh!
Spasiba!
Thank you!
I want to go.
You sound so nice, right?
Okay, okay, okay!
Okay, okay, okay.
Thank you so much!
Yeah, what is...
I actually... there was a book I read...
...a long time ago.
I can't remember.
I can't remember...
...what it was called.
But it was very...
...about...
...like, uh...
Vermeer's paintings, and...
...um...
It was... it was like a mystery...
...one of those mystery-type thing...
...like, books, where it's like...
...there's a hidden meaning in the painting!
Like, a national treasure-type thing.
Oh, it might have been Chasing Vermeer!
Hold on.
Maybe?
2004 Children's Mystery Novel.
Might have been.
Is that me in the painting?
Might be.
If I...
What if I...
Well, I don't look like her.
Maybe I was her, and then I...
...died, and then I reincarnated, and then I died again.
Was Vermeer a good runner?
Bust in his class!
Well, you can call someone up, and you'd be like...
Was your Vermeer running?
Because you better go chase it!
I live!
I die!
I live again!
And I died.
That one didn't take nearly as long as I thought it would.
I guess a 25 by 30 is pretty doable for us, huh?
We're that good.
Let's see.
We could do the 25 by 15.
Let's do that one.
It's such a strange shape.
I make it look easy.
No way.
Like I said, I feel like I'm actually quite slow at these.
Because I have to do so much counting.
Six.
Five.
Four.
Two.
Wait, okay.
One.
Two.
I should've...
Whatever.
Wait.
Six.
Ah!
No, no, no!
My finger slipped.
Wait, yeah, space.
Actually, I like to use these as the spaces.
Space.
Okay, so one.
Two.
One, two, three, four.
Maybe?
Oh, wait.
Five.
Maybe?
I can't tell if that's right or not.
I can't tell.
You're pretty good.
At these.
Your pace is steady.
Quite good, to be honest.
Well, thank you.
I don't have the patience for these games, but you do.
Oh my gosh, James Cameron.
Oh my gosh.
I was thinking about you earlier.
Because I was...
I was...
I don't remember why.
I think I was talking to a friend about my VOD for Deal or No Deal.
And then I was watching it.
And part of the part that I was watching...
You told me to...
To...
Pick one of the boxes.
And I did.
And I think it was the million.
And I was just like...
I was like, oh my gosh, James Cameron!
Yeah!
I think about you guys sometimes.
You know?
If I'm like out and about and I see something...
If I'm like haunting...
Doing my little, you know, ghostly paranormal activities...
I see something that reminds you of you guys.
I'll be like...
Oh my gosh!
Oh my gosh, that's like so and so.
I guess the parasocialism runs deep.
But it's just kind of like, I wonder how they're doing.
I hope they're okay.
I hope they're doing well.
You know?
Meow.
But, you know, because of my name, I bet you guys are thinking about me all the time, huh?
You guys, you brush your teeth and you're just like, mint flavored toothpaste.
Or you go to the store and you're just like, mint ice cream.
I'm everywhere.
I'm actually haunting.
For real.
Good branding.
Did the parasocial relationship just become social?
If you rainbow... Wait, what?
Don't rainbow.
If I rainbow super mint, she'll come through my monitor and call me stinky.
No, no, no.
You're thinking of Binto, my original character.
Do not steal.
I can safely say, eating mint ice cream has never been quite the same.
Hahaha.
Freak.
Yeah, because of the name.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Hmm.
I think about you every time I look at my arm.
Oh my gosh.
Sulk in your arm.
You're crazy.
Crazy.
One, two, three, four, five.
One, one.
One, two, three.
I think.
One, one, two, three, space.
One, two, three, four, five.
Oh.
I think?
But it still says there's more.
Actually, Bob in chocolate ice cream the other day and was thinking of you.
How are you spying on us?
I'm a ghost.
It's like my duty.
It's my job.
I had to cancel my food delivery because the store closed before they kick up a driver.
I ordered it at the start of stream.
What?
So I'm going to cook something instead so you can have the...
No!
Phil!
What?
That sucks so much though.
They're forcing you to be... to be responsible.
Wait, hold on.
Mint flavor stuff burns hotter than sriracha.
Is that like the same gene that makes it so that you hate?
What's that?
What's that one plant?
It's not...
It's, uh...
Cilantro!
I was like, parsley?
Yes, the cilantro!
Raise your hand if you have that.
If you can't eat cilantro.
Nadine's technically wrong about the chair.
Upholstery often use a polished brass capable of bright reflection.
So wait, hold on.
That's so interesting.
So as long...
Sorry, every time I click out of the window, it stops the music.
So as long as the sun shone directly on it through a window...
I've seen it with my own eye.
Really?
Upholstery often used a polished brass.
You're just...
You get flash banged by your chair.
It would suck.
I feel like I'm not doing this one quite right.
But this would be one.
One, two, three, four, five.
Okay, maybe...
Maybe...
Um...
Two, space.
One, two, three, space.
One...
Space.
One, two, space.
I don't understand this one.
This one's def...
Tricky.
Because of the...
I don't like when they're not as square.
I wish I could enjoy cilantro.
No!
It's wideness is overwhelming.
I know!
Why'd I get flash banged by Minto?
Stop.
Stop!
This one confuses me.
What am I missing?
What am I doing wrong?
Six.
One, two, three, four, five.
One, two, three, four.
One, two, one.
One, one, two.
One, two, three, four.
One, two, three, four, five.
One, two, three, four, five, six.
I suppose.
Would you rather play Sudoku for all eternity or eat a bowl of cilantro?
I can eat cilantro.
So give me that cilantro, baby.
Oh my gosh.
I've heard of people.
So there, you know, people will...
Oh!
Midcuts from Ayami's booth!
Yay!
Oh my gosh.
Thank you for ordering, Barely.
I love that thing where you say or do something IRL and you can instantly picture the chat's reactions.
No, I don't want to think about that.
I don't want to think about you guys perceiving me at all like that.
That's way too embarrassing.
But, um, going back to the eat a bowl of cilantro.
There are some people that are like, that are like, I'm not good at eating my veggies.
Not just veggies.
I'm not good at eating my leafy greens.
And so what they've done is they...
Just look how...
Oh my gosh.
I'm blocking her, but she's so cute when she stares at the puzzle.
Um, what they've done is they...
To make it so that they...
Will eat their leafy greens.
They call it Dinosaur Time.
And they pretend that they are a dinosaur.
And they eat their...
And apparently it really helps.
It's kind of awesome.
Just like tree stars.
I mean, they made the tree stars look so delicious.
They made them seem so delicious in the Land Before Time.
I feel like it has to work.
Dinosaur Time.
Dino Time.
That's...
That's my...
Life and afterlife hack.
Let's see.
One.
One, two, three, four.
Okay.
So it has to be...
One.
One, two, three, four.
But is it one, one?
Or...
Tricky.
Okay.
So if I did...
I think like...
One, space.
One, two, three, four.
Dinosaur.
Yeah.
This one is so long.
Confuses me.
I'd eat a dinosaur.
Don't do that.
It's probably really...
Tough.
What do you mean pretend?
Nah.
You can put an X there.
Wait, where?
Under there?
Under where?
We eat T-Rex's ancestors all the time.
True.
The hard ones are because of all the small numbers.
Yeah, that can be the case.
She said underwear.
I tricked the streamer into saying a silly word.
Oh, this one confuses me.
Two.
Ah.
What is this?
Nothing.
Click on it.
It does nothing.
Blue row.
You can mark the second tile as an X.
Second.
What?
This one.
Why?
But how?
Hmm.
Would missing a stream because of an ecchi convention be considered excused apps?
Wait.
What?
What's an ecchi convention?
Will you take Minto along?
Wait.
Second from the right.
Did I get it wrong?
This?
That's right.
I believe you.
I just don't know how you got it at all.
It's an 18 plus anime convention.
They have those?
I was lurking whilst exercising.
Can I go make dinner now?
Have a good dinner!
It's either two or one at the end.
Yeah.
So we can't mark anything else.
But we can do that.
Oh my gosh.
We only have one row that's blue.
Hold on.
Okay.
Only one row that's blue.
I hate this.
Two.
So let's just assume this is...
One.
I think we have to assume.
In that case.
One.
One, two, three.
One, one, one.
Like so.
That's right.
Yeah, because I don't think four...
Two, two...
Oh, what?
Oh yeah, because there's a one too.
Okay, so never mind.
So...
Oh wait.
Wow...
Gura gura gura gura gura.
Maitake maitake.
Gura gura gura gura.
Yes.
I messed up.
Oh, there we go.
I did too many.
Maitake maitake.
Gura gura gura gura.
Um...
Two here.
Gura gura gura.
Yes.
One, space.
One, two, three, four.
Uh oh.
My chat froze.
Give me one moment, please.
Distracted by ecchi convention.
I mean...
You aren't...
Incorrect.
But also...
Guys...
I...
What should we do for 400,000 subscribers?
We're gonna get there eventually.
I think?
What should we do?
Party!
E400,000 leaves of cilantro.
It's also spooky.
It's quite a spooky...
Achievement.
Pizza party.
New outfit reveal.
Oh, I might actually be able to do that.
Eat 400,000 hot dogs.
I'll sing a song 400,000 times.
Okay, so here is tricky because it could be two, one, four, or...
Two, one, and then four somewhere.
I'll sing there.
Count four...
Four, four, four, K pennies.
Yeah, but that would be four, four, four, four, K, no?
Oh...
I sang...
I've sung...
Uh...
Ikenai Borderline 50 times.
I feel like I could have the endurance to sing a song 100 times.
Even 101 times.
I think.
Ban 400,000 wisps.
True.
How are we supposed to...
No!
I'm sorry I'm yawning now.
I don't know.
Because this could be...
Wait.
This could be...
No, wait, no.
Just wait.
One, two, three, four, one.
See?
I don't know.
This one's tricking me out.
I know you guys are trying to help, but...
I...
I get confused.
Yeah, maybe 400K will do outfit reveal.
I still have some stuff I need to prepare though.
The weird dimensions throwing you off.
Yeah, I think so.
I think so.
See?
Because...
This could be four.
Wait.
Can it?
Yeah, it can.
Hmm.
Or it could be two...
Four, one.
Conventions have been censored nowadays.
I remember someone talking about their whole booth getting removed just for regular Higurashi merch.
I know some conventions have rules based on how much fan art you can have.
Versus, like, original goods.
Mint, I need to take care of my voice.
Also, Mint.
I didn't say I was going to sing.
I just said I could.
If I wanted to.
No!
It's already been 20 minutes with this one.
Help!
Wait.
Is there a hint system in this?
Jump to Matsu Takeo!
Hint!
I'm not trying to help Mint.
Don't worry.
No!
Please!
Column 7 put an X between the two boxes.
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven.
How do you know?
What if you did four activities simultaneously for 100 minutes to show your ultimate power?
Four.
Ha ha ha ha!
Easy mode.
Because it can't be your four.
Oh!
I see it now!
I see it!
You're right!
Yes.
Twinkle dogs reunion.
Let's see.
This has to be... R3.
Yeah.
Wait.
Now I remember why I didn't... Hold on.
Because it could be 1, 3, 1, 1.
You know?
It could be connected to the 5.
What do the blue numbers mean?
The blue numbers mean that there's a part that is solvable on the row.
So... But I don't know.
We only have two quote-unquote columns that have things that are able to be placed.
Yeah.
Enough info to solve a square.
I'm like, what info?
Huh?
Are we looking at the same thing?
None of this feels solvable right now.
We have no errors.
Yeah?
Let me double-check.
Just wait a minute.
Nope.
We are all good.
We keep our brains today.
Think if it could be 3 or 1, what would be the same?
That this is...
Naruhono.
Next.
What do you mean, though?
Huh?
What do you mean, why?
Because if it's 3, it's like this.
And then that would have to be 1.
Wait.
I'll mix it myself up.
Or...
Or if it's 1 and this is 3, then it's like that.
Like that.
So either way, that is an X.
Maetake, maetake, gulu, gulu, gulu, gulu.
Oh.
Oh, yeah.
But it can be a 1.
It can't.
It can't be a 1.
Oh, wait.
You're right.
It can be a 1.
I saw it immediately, as soon as you said it.
Oh, golly.
My brain is very slow today.
Why did I think that?
Curious.
I don't like this one.
It's making me angry.
I don't like this.
The one below it is an X, though.
No.
Because what if it's 3?
Or I should do the middle clicks.
What if it's like 3?
I like that.
One, three.
Wait, I messed up all... I don't like doing the middle clicks.
Oh, wait.
Maybe I just got the position wrong.
This is the X.
Maybe that's what I was visualizing and I did it wrong.
You want to like it when Mint gets angry.
Yeah, okay.
I was like, wait a second.
I know I was seeing a vision somewhere there.
That didn't open up anything else for... It closed that row, but it didn't open up... Or that column, but it didn't open up anything else.
Hold on.
I'm gonna get... Uh, uh, throat Mint.
There it is.
Thank you guys for your help.
Let's see.
Now this one.
This is the one that's gonna...
Help a lot.
Hopefully.
With opening new doors.
So currently, it could be one, two.
One, two, three, four, one.
Like so.
Or it could be...
One, two, three, four somewhere.
And one up here somewhere.
And two down here somewhere.
You're like Coke Zero Sugar.
If you know, you know.
I don't know.
If I know, I know.
Don't worry about it then.
I never had a Coke before.
I don't know what it tastes like.
So what's...
Is it like a...
Is it...
Are you saying that I taste...
I...
I have less sweetness than...
The original...
Zero calorie?
Worse than normal Coke?
It's gross.
Is it?
Oh yeah.
The aspartame.
Is that the sugar that they use?
You haven't?
No.
I can't drink soda.
So I've never had it before.
Hmm.
What does it mean?
Let's see here.
There.
There's one.
I think...
Oh wait.
Yeah.
This is an X.
I don't wanna...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
It shouldn't be so hard.
It shouldn't be so difficult.
There we go.
My goodness gracious.
Like that, right?
There we go.
It really just takes one thing...
To kind of set things into motion.
Okay, let's see.
Three...
Space...
Two...
One...
Space...
Like so.
Do be like that.
Do be.
Four.
Cool.
Like so.
I love...
That is nice, they are...
Cool.
Guys also,
I forget...
Tikes...
Three...
Why, yes...
Too good.
It's a silly, cute name.
Yeah, it's so fun.
Love saying her name.
Okay, so this is four.
Space.
It would be like that.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay.
This one, I don't know if it's two...
or if it's part of... like, two up here...
and part of the four.
To one...
Oh, whoops.
My bad.
I'm stupid.
Um...
Two here.
One space.
Like that.
Three.
I see.
Good night, Minuto.
Good night.
Good night, good night.
Let's see...
Hmm, hmm.
Hmm...
Wait, okay.
Two...
This has to be...
Ouch!
I just open my tongue.
Has to be like that, right?
I believe.
I believe...
Still no idea what it's supposed...
It just...
It looks...
It looks like a worm.
Everything looks like a worm to me.
I can't stop seeing worms everywhere.
It's all worms.
Do you see the curly tail?
And this is the head?
It looks like a little lima bean or something.
I can't stop seeing worm.
Oh.
Hmm, hmm.
There we go.
Oh my gosh.
It took so long for us to get here, but finally...
We're making progress, finally.
It took us so long.
We'll helm the worm.
I would love Minto if she were a worm.
I don't believe that.
Are you guys worm savers?
If you see a worm on the sidewalk on a hot dry day, do you send him back to the...
To the pits of dirt?
Hmm, hmm.
Yeah, yeah.
Me too, me too.
I try to at least...
Wait, okay.
One, two, one...
Three...
Two, two.
That should be it.
I say back to your dirty ways, dirty worm.
I don't go outside.
That's so...
That's...
That's fair.
That's fair, but would you be the type?
Do you think...
If you saw a worm, would you stop and help?
Have no sympathy for black widows, though.
I don't...
That's a complete...
That's not a...
That's not a worm.
I don't think anybody is telling you to have sympathy for black widows.
Yatta!
Sugooi!
I think that's a little...
That's not even the same.
Ah, let's see...
Two...
One...
Hum, hum.
Yes...
We're almost there!
We almost got it!
Are worms bugs?
They're...
They're gummy.
It's a kiwi bird?
Sugooi!
Where do you see this?
With your eyes.
Yatta!
Ah!
Nehihi...
Not...
Uh-oh!
Uh...
I made a lot of mistakes.
Huh?
Oh!
Yeah, I see.
Okay.
Oh, I...
I don't goofed!
Was that right?
Okay.
More!
This one.
Okay.
Ah!
No sympathy for...
Uber eats robots that fell over the street, though.
I don't know, I feel like I see those dogs.
Hum, hum.
Sugoi!
The dogs that, like, do...
Ii ne!
That...
They're not Uber, but you know, like, people will keep pushing them over and stuff.
Sorry, I cheated so much.
It's because my brain is slow today.
Yatta!
Oh!
You know, the robot dogs?
They're pretty cute, though.
I've raised butterflies and found my first eggs of the season!
You see, worms?
You might be excited to hear this.
I've got monarchs and swallowtails!
That's so sweet!
Wait, that's actually so sweet!
I used to grow butterflies.
Worms or caterpillars?
They're a little different, huh?
They...
They are a little different.
Just don't worry about it.
Hum, hum.
Sugoi!
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
Yes, yes.
Yes.
Yatta!
Yes, yes, yes.
My eyes are so heavy right now.
You guys don't even understand.
I don't want to end stream early, but...
I'm like...
I'm so...
I think it's...
But I don't want to go to sleep because when I wake up, I have to go!
No!
Yatta!
I don't want to go tomorrow.
You can't make me!
Sugoi!
I was catching up to you.
I thought I was over the jet lag.
I thought I was over it.
Yes, yes, yes.
It's good.
Yatta!
Sugoi!
One, one...
I'll hear...
Wait, it's a swan!
It's a...
It's a bird!
Good!
What is that?
I was right!
What the hell?
I decided to race against you.
Just finished.
Yeah, me too.
No, I think.acăあせりんの作品で、たまごを犬から守るコブハクチョウが大体実寸大サイズで描されています。
That's true, this lag.
This figures lag.
You can see the文字 on the floor, and that they're in the foot of the heart of football.
No, I think...
I think someone knows how...um...wait...oh wait, the enemy of the state was a bo...I didn't even notice this was a dog.
I think someone knows that...that geese are evil...even though it's a swan.
But swans...I guess swans are mean too.
Look at that.
There's no way that's a nice swan.
I like geese though.
I love geese.
But...you cannot deny...that they are pretty evil.
Swans are extremely mean.
Swan geese by association.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So...I think that this person had a...tricky run-in.
With a swan and said they are the enemy of the state.
That's my artistic...analysis.
That is my...grand artistic analysis.
What I want to do is not do...a 25 by 20...oh maybe 20 by 20.
Maybe that's okay.
Maybe that'll be okay then, 15 by 15.
Okay, let's try it.
Attempt.
Oh...uh...
Not attempt.
Let's do a 15 by 15 and I'll call it there.
Oh, whoops.
Went the wrong way.
Where are all the 15 by 15s?
Where are they?
Oh, Japanese painting.
Okay, we'll try it.
15 by 15 is extremely cozy.
I can do these fast.
Most of the time.
Most of the time, at least.
Yatta!
Wait, did I go too far?
Yes.
Keys don't even feel the need to run away...
when you walk through a swarm of them.
Should tell you all you need to know.
I once saw a video of a...goose that landed in a tiger pin.
Sugoi!
Wait, yeah.
And a tiger pin.
And...
The tiger was like...
Yatta!
That's a little snacky for me.
And the goose literally attacked him and was just like...
Back the hell off.
And then the tiger was like...
I'm sorry, ma'am.
I'm sorry.
Sugoi!
Okay.
Gese.
The geese are crazy.
I'm sorry.
Yatta!
Oh, so this is just so easy.
Maybe we can do another one.
I don't know.
Wait, what did I get wrong?
Wait, uh, why... there we go.
There we go.
It's a puppy?
This is where I asked if you've played an untitled goose game.
Oh, for Anna!
I'm sorry, Anna.
It's too much fun to describe the appearance of the nature of the nature.
Oh, okay.
In this movie, it's a lovely little girl, which is a beautiful feeling.
The face is painted on the face.
So cute!
Okay, I saw one last, 15 by 15.
We can get this done out of the way.
Easy too!
Sorry, I'm obsessed, Hajime!
I'm obsessed with... game.
I'm obsessed.
I'm obsessed with this.
That's it!
Amazing!
Wait, I'll do the one too... Yes... Just
one more famous last words.
I don't think... as much as I would... I don't think I even have... the strength... I don't have the strength to go...
Go on!
Not the yawning virus... I've got it... I've got this... the tired... The tired... Oh gosh, okay... Okay... I'm okay... A hundred more fifteen by fifteens later... Oh no though... I'm getting real sleepy...
Come on, come on... Oh... I'm awake... Have
time...
Okay, yes... One... Space two... Space two... Space one... Okay... Yes... Yes... Yes...
Yes, maybe.
Oh, that one was... I should have gotten that one from the beginning.
Whoopsie.
It's fine, I'm sleepy as well.
It's just one of those days, you know?
What's today, Monday?
Yeah.
Lazy Monday.
Well, not lazy, but you know when you...
Mondays make you feel a certain way.
Thank you, Garfield.
The angry...
The angry of Buzhi is so funny.
Okay.
Hold on.
Good.
Morale is dead on Mondays.
Yeah, but you just gotta look forward to next...
To the Friday again.
And that'll get you motivated.
To be like, yeah, Friday will come...
Once again.
Eventually.
The peak collab.
Yeah, that's on Friday.
That's right.
Oh.
I did it!
Don't do that.
That's right.
I just called them Minto Monday.
I guess we'll have to see what...
The doctor says tomorrow, though.
Oh, whoops.
Because, uh...
That could change my schedule if they're just like...
Missy!
No talking!
Forever.
Hopefully, they don't say that.
That's right.
But you know...
Good news, we all hope.
Yeah!
Minto of the sleepless.
What is your wisdom?
Don't become sleepless!
Don't do it!
Don't...
Don't become sleepless!
This one's taken me just a little bit longer...
Because my brain...
Well, my brain's been shut down.
My brain has been shut down.
Wait, two...
One...
Very good.
Two...
One...
Wait...
Huh?
Okay...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, golly.
If they went that far...
Saying never talk again...
Probably would want to give a second opinion.
It's true!
Well, if you need to stay awake...
Remember to use code BOOBER...
For that extra energy...
With giver subs!
What if the doctor prescribes...
Turkish delight?
Huh...
Second opinion...
Second opinion!
You can't force me...
To enjoy Turkish delight...
It's not a delight for me...
Everybody has a different opinion...
I like the way she says that part...
I like the way she says...
I like it!
That's it!
Mm, mm!
Almost there?
I like it!
Yuffie!
A
little pause... Wait!
We just have this with the puppies?鈴木キーツはリンパの画家
坂井邦逸に指示して絵の研鑽を積みました。師匠が亡くなった後はリンパの伝統を踏襲しつつも 自分ならではの表現を追求したそうです。
鈴木キーツは染物職人の家に生まれた という話もあって、染物で培った色彩感覚が本作の刺激的ともいえる色使いに
影響したかもしれませんね。背景の金色と朝顔とのコントラストが 目に焼き付いて思わず引き込まれてしまいます。わー!
っそいい!いや、 if I have to do some no-talking streams...I might do that.so that I...um...can still stream and rest my voice.ん...
allegiance
?なんだけど...えー...and...cause I was making my schedule .Today .I'm not gonna lie, I felt so depressed.
Because I was just like, I don't want to take this many days off.
I know I have to, but...
I have your med song.
My med song?
What's my alarm for taking my nighttime medication and you jump scare me nightly?
What's my med song?
But thanks!
Just a few months.
I think until September, you know, obviously we'll have to see.
Especially after tomorrow.
What the diagnosis is.
I think resting mostly until September would be good.
But we'll see, we'll see.
Hoping for good news tomorrow.
Try not to stress too much.
I'm sure it'll be over before you know it.
Thank you!
ASMR typing strings.
We're up for whatever type of stream we need while recovering.
Thank you!
I don't think I could do text-to-speech stream.
I don't think I could.
Yeah, I'll definitely let you guys know how things go.
Of course, of course.
No talking charade stream.
Oh my gosh, I'm forced to use 3D.
Because it's the only way I can communicate.
I know a little bit of ASL.
American Sign Language.
My WPM?
It's like 90 something.
But still, I feel like it's...
I don't know.
I talk too much.
I have too much that I want to say.
And...
Typing would not be...
Efficient.
Sending all my energy for tomorrow.
Thank you guys.
Thank you.
Puppy.
I guess Japan likes morning glories.
Wait, is it the same...
No, it's not even the same...
The same person.
Hello guys!
Thank you.
Uh...
I'll let you guys know how my doctor's appointment goes.
And if you're watching the VOD...
Then you might already know!
Talking using the 15...
By 15 seconds...
Huh?
Good luck, have a good night.
Thank you!
It'll be okay tomorrow.
Oh gosh, you scared me.
Welcome!
You're welcome!
Guifu-tei-la-renga-gu-an-nai!
Pixel Museum!
I don't know that tomorrow.
You'll be in and out before you know it.
Hopefully...
Margo, thank you!
Pain, thank you!
Thank you guys.
Otsumi-ta!
I'll see you guys...
When I see you next.
Thank you so much for...
for...
uh...
indulging me in my Nonogram obsession.
And...
um...
Yeah.
Otsumi-ta, otumi-ta!
Hello, oh my gosh.
Toziko, your icon is so cute.
Have a good sleep.
You as well.
I'm gonna have a good night.
I'll see you guys later.
Bye-bye.
I'll do my best tomorrow.
I'll be brave.
Hi, dog.
Thank you, Joy Princess.
Bye-bye.